Frau Müller vielleicht die erste Frage
an Sie sind Schulleiterin an einer
Haupt- und Realschule genau
niedersachsen-oberschule aber das stimmt
haben dieses Buch gemacht dass ich immer
erwähnt habe wie verlieren unsere Kinder
und dann der Untertitel der Verstörung
der Alltag im klassenchat was war der
Anlass für dieses Buch
der Anlass sind ganz viel Erfahrung die
sich in den letzten Jahren tatsächlich
angesammelt haben und da möchte ich
vorweg sagen das ist tatsächlich auch
vor pandemisch wir schieben ganz viele
immer auf die corona-krise das hat damit
nichts zu tun total interessanter mir
gings genauso und Frederik Obermeier
sagt was ähnliches ist wie wir reden uns
gerade so ein bisschen raus und schieben
alles auf Corona aber das was Sie
beschreiben hat schon lange vorher
begonnen das muss man tatsächlich auch
konzentrieren denn wenn ich so eine Zeit
zurück gucke 2018 lässt sich das
ziemlich genau
begleitet mit der Entwicklung von tiktok
und dem Aufstieg sozusagen dieser
Plattform tiktok also ungefähr kann
sagen für uns gefühlt ja an der Schule
und in dem Begegnungen mit all dem was
ich in dem Buch Schilder das heißt
tatsächlich der Zugang zu Gewalt
verherrlichen Videos zu rassistischen
Mims das heißt so Fotos mit Sprüchen
homophoben Äußerungen oder eben auch
Bildern tatsächlich bis hin natürlich zu
und das kennen wir aus der eigenen
Schulzeit selbstverständlich auch noch
diese Mobbing Gedanken die aber eben zu
diesem sogenannten cybermob werden und
deutlich mehr verbreitet werden und
deutlich mehr tatsächlich Zugang finden
auf die Smartphones der Kinder wenn sie
über diese Gewaltvideos sagten sie
gerade ja wir reden über Kinder über
Jugendliche was ich selbst das Setzen
dieser Runde solche Gewaltvideos wir in
der Form teilweise noch gar nicht
gesehen haben also ich bin immer wieder
schockiert ich spreche von Folter das
heißt Kastration eines Mannes die nicht
im OP-Saal stattfindet ich spreche
tatsächlich ja tatsächlich sehen Kinder
ein Video in dem ein Mann kastriert wird
also ich habe eine anatomische
Fortbildung mal gemacht wenn sie so
möchten das heißt sie sehen dann
tatsächlich das Live und ungeschnitten
und das sind Bilder die mir als
Erwachsener schwer fallen das zu sehen
und bei Kindern in Gruppen auf
unterschiedlichste Art und Weise Land
man kann gar nicht sagen das ist immer
nur per WhatsApp oder per snapchat
weitergeleitet sondern das sind
teilweise Videos die die Kinder abfilmen
ob das bei tiktok ist ob das bei anderen
Plattform ist es gibt ganz viele reddits
Twitch ich könnte
es gibt viele aufzählen aber irgendwo
landet es und wenn die Kinder
tatsächlich im jüngsten alter ich
spreche von 12 Jahren 13-jährigen
14-jährigen Kindern völlig unvorbereitet
auf diese alleine auf diese Bilder wo
sie noch keine eigene Betroffenheit
eigentlich haben treffen ist das ja
schauerlich vor allen Dingen weil man
auch merkt dass die Kinder eine absolute
pharrhoheit mit dem also die sind
verroht das steuern sie aus dieses oh
Gott gibt es fast gar nicht mehr und
dieses oh Gott gucken Sie mal
woher haben sie das also und in welchem
Kontext in welcher Situation die die
zeigen sich das gegenseitig oder
schicken ist rum oder ich glaube sie
müssen sich einfach vorstellen dass wenn
ich meinem Kind ein Smartphone in die
Hand drücke dann ist das der Wurf ist
Haifischbecken ins unbegleitet ne und
Haifischbecken werden wir uns alle einig
ist gefährlich ähm tatsächlich haben die
Kinder meist unbeschränkten Zugang zu
einem das bedeutet ich wenn eine
Filtertechnologien auf der Fritzbox an
ich versuche Verbote auszusprechen
Zeiten zu regulieren aber selbst eine
Stunde reicht treffe ich sozusagen unter
die Räder zu geraten und wenn man davon
ausgeht dass die Kinder auf Plattform
unterwegs sind auf der Content geteilt
wird also Inhalte geteilt wird
der einfach wirklich sehr sehr Gewalt
verherrlichen ist und schlimmer ist als
Horror Videos dann fragen Sie wo wird
das denn überall geteilt und dann würde
ich sagen überall wo Kinder unterwegs
sind besteht mindestens die Gefahr dass
sie mit solchen content in Berührung
kommen
welche Rolle spielt die Schule dabei ein
großer also ich würde das sofort weiten
wollen und sagen Schule ist ein Teil
des auffangens für Kinder und das
behüteten Raums mit Sicherheit für
Kinder und der Prävention für Kinder
ganz sicher wir können aber eigentlich
ehrlicherweise und das ist auch die
Aussage meines Buches das nicht
voneinander trennen deswegen
gesamtgesellschaftliche Aufgabe haben
die Kinder zu begleitende zugehört
Politik wo wir möglicherweise über
Regulationen sogar nachdenken müssen
dazu gehören natürlich Elternhäuser der
zugehört und journalistischer
Aufarbeitung also ich bin sehr dankbar
dass dieses Thema auch heute gehört
findet denn allein Schule dann kommt die
Forderung nach wir führen ein neues Fach
ein wenn es heute Medienkunde ist es
morgen das Unterrichtsfach Glück was
immer dann irgendwie eingeführt werden
soll um alle Probleme zu heilen
dann ist das nicht förderlich dass
tatsächlich zu isolieren das heißt diese
Diskussion müssen wir aufmachen und
diese Diskussion müssen wir gemeinsam
führen der Bereich von Schule bedeutet
für Lehrkräfte dass wir nicht mehr sagen
können und für Schulleiter mensch das
ist ja nachmittags passiert wir sind uns
alle einig im Vormittagsbereich passiert
kaum was auf den Kinder Smartphones ja
man unsere Schule auch ein Smartphone
Verbot tatsächlich obwohl wir sehr
digital ausgerichtet sind aber selbst
wenn Kinder am Abend spät in der Nacht
das für mich ein Rätsel ist warum Eltern
ihren Kindern das Smartphone im
Kinderzimmer belassen
ich spät in der Nacht sowas passiert und
die Kinder bringen diesen Druck meistens
eigener Betroffenheit mit in die Schule
dann ist es ein Thema der Schule dann
bedeutet es ich muss auffangen ich muss
begleiten ich meine mein Blick geht
gerade zufällig Obermeier der ganz ganz
viele auf Plattformen unterwegs ist sie
können sich das wahrscheinlich sehr gut
vorstellen dass man an alles dran kommt
was man sich vorstellen kann dass man
alles dran kommt aber die Vorstellung
dass das mein Kind anschaut
ich muss selber was für möglich dass
Kinder daran kommen dass man ja total
einfach ich glaube das
Illusion die wir die man ich bin in der
Zeit aufgewachsen wo dann ins Internet
gerade gekommen ist wo ich gelernt habe
und ich riesig gefreut habe ist so
dieses fiepende Modem daheim hatten aber
unsere Kinder wissen natürlich wie
schnell man was findet die Google viel
besser als wir sie wissen auch zum Teil
sogar schon wie man irgendwie ins dark
Web kommt das ist ich glaube da machen
wir das gar keine also oder ich begeben
Smartphone haben der Punkt das wenn ich
das Ergänzen darf sie googeln eben nicht
mehr sondern sie müssen sich vor zehn
vorstellen da sitzen Kindern in einem
vollen Schulbus und ganz viele Kinder
haben dann tatsächlich auch ein iPhone
und das besitzt diese Funktion ist eher
droppens das heißt Kinder sparen ja
jederzeit Datenvolumen ne damit nicht
irgendwie das eingeschränkt wird weiter
zu surfen bei hoher Geschwindigkeiten
die Technologie praktisch
genau das von Gerät zu Gerät einfach
versuch mal in präventionsmomenten den
Kindern zu sagen mach es aus bitte ne
macht diese airdrop-funktion einfach aus
dass hier nichts gesendet werden kann
aber kinder sind neugierig wie auch
selbstverständlich ist dann diese
Funktion an und wenn da zum Beispiel
steht der Markus möchte dir ein Foto
senden ein Video senden dann nehme ich
es an da kann ich noch so oft zu Hause
predigen mach es nicht wenn du nicht
weißt von wem ich mache es trotzdem weil
die Neugier einfach sieht und dann ist
es eben nicht mehr dieser Moment wo ich
entscheiden kann ob ich ein Video sehe
oder nicht ob ich ein Foto sehe oder
nicht sondern es spielt sich direkt
einfach ab es ist in der Galerie und es
spielt sich und das Sehen möglicherweise
wenn ich von dem kastrationsvideo
spreche Grundschüler die mit in den Bus
sind
die ja also die Diskussion beginnt
sicherlich auch da wann haben Kinder
eigentlich schon Zugriff auf ein
Smartphone das ist eine große Diskussion
die wir führen müssen aber tatsächlich
können wir sie nicht schützen davor dass
sie auf Inhalte Zugriff haben
jederzeit an jedem Ort
sie haben gerade voll das Wort verroom
benutzt wie äußert sich das
zusammen die Übertragung von der
digitalen in die analoge Welt die echte
Welt der Punkt die Kinder dieser
Unterscheidung nicht treffen in der
Generation jetzt das heißt wir machen
einen entscheidenden Fehler dass wir von
außen auf die Kinder gucken mit unserer
Bewertung wir teilen und sagen aha die
sind wieder online und wieder im Netz
komm doch mal zurück in die normale Welt
für Kinder und das fällt mir immer
schwerer das anzuerkennen und auch zu
verstehen ist das Leben im Netz so würde
ich schon ausdrücken Teil der Kinder und
Jugendkultur
das heißt die trennen auch nicht
miteinander wenn sie miteinander online
kommunizieren oder analog kommuniziert
sie kommunizieren das heißt tatsächlich
auch dass sie sie haben es eben in der
in der Anmoderation gesagt dass
man ganz viele Fragen stellen muss woher
kommt das welchen Content haben sie und
so weiter ich glaube wir müssen uns
eingestehen dass wir an vielen Stellen
wirklich ganz katastrophal versagt haben
sowohl in den politischen
Voraussetzungen in dem in der
pädagogischen Anerkenntnis was das
passiert
Gesellschaft also nicht nur sozusagen
die Eltern
und wir haben einen ein Problem vor der
Brust dass man auch nicht mehr
verharmlosen kann und dass wir auch
nicht eben durch Lösung wie wir führen
einfach ein wir müssen mehr wir haben
tolle Präventionsprojekte in unserem
Land und präventions
Mitarbeiter und Medienpädagogen das ist
ganz tolle Arbeit die da läuft aber wir
müssen uns einfach eingestehen
es wird dich und wir verlieren die
Kinder und deswegen der provokative
Titel das ist mir klar dass der Titel
sehr provokativ ist an eine verrohende
Welt weil sie und darum geht es und
diese Verrohung ist eben da weil sie
möglicherweise kaum noch Empathie spüren
wenn sie nicht selber betroffen sind
weil es vielleicht die Kinder sind die
sich dann eben nicht mehr erheben und
einsetzen und sagen moment mal das geht
doch nicht so und dieses veronde ist
auch der Moment wenn ich gucke was ich
Kinder wirklich bis zum Ende anschauen
können das ist für mich total
erschreckend wie gleichgültig sozusagen
man Inhalte hinnehmen kann
ich auch tatsächlich
er wird noch mal wie äußert sich das
dann also diese verrogen im digitalen es
gibt ja dann auch wenn sie sagen das ist
ein interessanter Gedanke auch und auch
ein Satz den sie immer wieder schreiben
Kinder sind immer on ja genau
so so trivial aber es hat natürlich wenn
man anfängt mal darüber nachzudenken
eine echte Konsequenz weil es ja
bedeutet dass die Kinder immer auch für
Mobbing z.B das hört ja nie auf genau du
kommst mit dem Telefon nach Hause du
hast es im Kinderzimmer dabei das heißt
das Mobbing endet nicht im Bus oder auf
dem Schulhof es geht immer weiter und
auch nachts um 12 Uhr und auch nachts um
zwei richtig und ich glaube wenn sie
sagen wie veräußert sich oder wie äußert
sich die Verrohung sind wir sehr leicht
immer in der Debatte und sagen da werden
die Kinder jetzt gewalttätiger und wir
haben die neue Kriminalstatistik die
Zeit die Zahlen nehmen zu und wir haben
eklatan schlimme Fälle jetzt in der
Vergangenheit gehabt wo man sagt ist
sind das jetzt die Auswirkungen da habe
ich keine Expertise um das zu bewerten
ob das wirklich diese Auswertungen
feststelle
ist genau der Punkt den sie ansprechen
wenn wir über Cybermobbing sprechen
konnten Kinder früher mir wird dann
immer gesagt naja früher gab es auch
Auseinandersetzung und Mobbing und jetzt
hängt das nicht so hoch ist konnten die
Kinder sich im Kinderzimmer zurückziehen
sie wussten okay ich treffe morgen
wieder auf die aber morgen wenn sie
jetzt zum Kinderzimmer sind wissen sie
das läuft weiter du bleibst 24 Stunden
und zwar auf übelste Art und Weise und
was Kinder sich alleine in der
Formulierung schreiben also was man in
den klassenchats wirklich liest was wie
sie sich beschimpfen wie sie die Mütter
beschimpfen wie sie sagen was sie mit
einem machen würden auf sexueller Art
und Weise diese verrote Sprache an sich
wir sind auf dem Land wir sind wirklich
auf dem Dorf bei uns in hatten ähm und
ich würde sagen bei uns ist noch ein
bisschen die Welt tatsächlich eher in
Ordnung
selbst da kriege ich ja mit wie Kinder
miteinander umgehen und wie sie
miteinander sprechen ich werde ganz oft
von Kollegen auch aus dem Bundesgebiet
weil wir gut vernetzen angerufen gesagt
wir haben hier einen Fall was sollen wir
tun sind immer die gleichen Äußerungen
die gleichen Schilderungen und oftmals
übrigens auch wieder die Trennung von
uns analog und digital haben wir ein
Trend auf einer Plattform wie tiktok und
Co haben wir den in der Schule das heißt
genau das was Kinder dort in Videos
sehen wird in schauspielerischer
Höchstleistung dann möglicherweise im
analogen umgesetzt ich mache mal
triviales Beispiel es gab eine Challenge
da ging es darum dass es Toilettenpapier
fragen Sie mich nach nicht nach den
Grund an Toiletten Wende zu werfen so
das ist wirklich Schmiererei und echt
viel Arbeit war das aufzuräumen es hat
einen Moment lang gedauert wir hatten
diesen Trend auch bei uns in der Schule
um zu verstehen was das ist warum bis
wir dahinter kamen das ist ein Trend bei
tiktok viel schlimmer ist aber
tatsächlich das ist Trends gibt die
mir wirklich Sorge machen ich sag mal
die das was ich auch Schilder es gab
eine Challenge die heißt für was ich
blauen würde da sprechen wir von der
Sexualpraktik das muss man so deutlich
aussprechen und dann müssen sich
vorstellen tiktok funktioniert im
Rhythmus so das sind ganz Kurzvideos die
mittlerweile ja schon deutlich länger
geworden sind als nur 15 Sekunden die
Möglichkeit sich zu präsentieren da
sitzen dann oder Liegen oder Stehen
Kinder meist im sehr sehr jungen
Pubertätsalter in ihren Kinderzimmer auf
dem Betten wie auch immer machen diese
selfie-posten dahinter läuft eine Rap
Musik wo es um Luxus und so weiter geht
es steht der Hashtag für was ich blauen
würde und dann steht da beispielsweise
eine Einzel Mathematik die neuen Schuhe
die neue Taschen ich weiß nicht ob es
dann nur mir so geht dass ich das
tatsächlich eher der Prostitution
zuordnen würde und keiner passt auf weil
Kinder können das nicht einschätzen die
Folgen diesem Trend völlig unbedarft
erwachsene Männer können diesen Accounts
folgen wenn Mädchen das machen da sind
wir beim sogenannten cybergrooming das
heißt der in den Angriffen von außen um
Kinder zu sexuellen Handlungen zu wecken
Nacktbilder die verschickt werden
gruselig Nacktbilder das vielleicht noch
zu Ende zu führen auch Intimität wenn
wir Analogie analog und digital nicht
mehr teilen intime erst Erfahrungen sind
nicht mehr die intimärzerfahrung im
Kinderzimmer sondern der Austausch
digitalen Raum gehört für die Kinder
mittlerweile auch für selbstverständlich
dazu und dann wird sich ein
unbekleidetes Foto oder ein Foto wo man
unbegleitet ist geschickt
als Vertrauensbeweis und wenn eine
jugendliche Liebe eben nicht mehr so
lange hält und möglicherweise im Streit
auseinander geht weiß man auch was
möglicherweise mit den Fotos passiert
sie am interessanten Vergleich gemacht
aus der analogen Welt und sagen es will
liegt fast Säule ja und wenn man wenn
man jemandem sagen würde pass auf also
das hängen wir morgen an Litfaßsäulen
bundesweit kann jeder sehen dann
erschrecken die sich und sagen Himmels
Willen auf gar keinen Fall aber nichts
anderes sagen sie ist das was dort im
digitalen passiert digitalsäule wissen
sie das Problem ist dass wir dieser
Generation die jetzt und zum Leben
übrigens auch voraus ist im Handeln im
Netz
dass wir die haben laufen lassen und
dass wir diese Bilder vergessen haben
tatsächlich von dem Moment wo sie dieses
Smartphone in die Hand bekommen zu sagen
pass mal auf es gibt keine zwei Seiten
und die Diskussion um die Privatsphäre
die würde ich so weit noch mitgeben wenn
ich mit jemandem im Einzel Chat ne
diskutiere oder schreibe oder wie auch
immer das ist meinetwegen noch privat
sobald ein zweiter ein dritter in die
Gruppe dazu kommt
muss ich dem Kind sofort klar machen es
ist eben nicht mehr privat sondern es
reicht ein Screenshot einfach schicken
wo anders hin dann hängt es öffentlich
am schwarzen Brett in der Schule sage
ich mal genau ja digitale liegt was
sollen bevor wir gleich zu Frau Prien
und dann auch Heide kommen sie sagen
nach Freudenberg das war ein Fall der
die deutsche Öffentlichkeit wirklich
aufgeschreckt hat
da hätte man tiktok abschalten müssen ja
warum
also der Fall fällt mir tatsächlich auch
in der Nachbetrachtung noch sehr schwer
denn ich erinnere mich an den Tag in dem
uns die Nachricht erreicht und ich mit
meinem Kollegen der bei uns diese
sogenannte Social Network Sprechstunde
über die ich auch ein Buch spreche
betreut mein Lehrerzimmer saßen und
gesagt haben okay bitte bitte lass es
keinen Zusammenhang mit sozialen
Netzwerken haben und es dauerte nur
wenige Stunden bis ich bestätigt hatte
dass es mindestens ein Zusammenhang
insofern gibt als dass die Profile der
Täterin des Opfers gelegt worden also
veröffentlicht worden bei tiktok sehr
sehr schnell das heißt man konnte mit
klaren Bildern Fotografien die Accounts
der Täterinnen und das Opfer sehen bei
tiktok
es begann wir haben das verfolgt
tatsächlich wie eine Hetzjagd eine
Hexenjagd das kann man nicht anders
sagen
und es reicht da halt nicht dass diese
Accounts natürlich sehr schnell gesperrt
und entfernt wurden sondern sie müssen
sich ja dann vorstellen jeder hat Bilder
von diesen Kindern und es wurde über die
anderen und weitere und Mitschüler
Accounts weiter verbreitet aber nicht
nur über die Kinder über die Familien
über die Schule über die Mitschüler
wie man das aushalten kann sowieso
diesen ganzen Falter ist unerträglich
und unsagbar
aber wie das auch dann tatsächlich
Lehrer verkraften wie das die Mitschüler
verkraften und ich verstehe nicht warum
keine Medien Ethik am dem Zeitpunkt
gegriffen hat dass man gesagt hat Stopp
mit jeglicher Berichterstattung zum
Schutz aller die hier beteiligt sind
denn es wurde medial sehr sehr viel
darüber berichtet sicherlich im
aufklärerischen Sinne teilweise im
reißerischen Sinne aber es ging eben im
Netz wo die Kinder unterwegs sind
permanent weiter das bis heute übrigens
nicht gestoppt ne es kommt immer wieder
irgendwas hoch die Frage an die
Journalistin meine wie machen uns ja
ganz häufig genau diese Gedanken und
fragen uns okay an welcher Stelle endet
dann sozusagen der Auftrag zur
Informationspflicht und und wo betrifft
es dann möglicherweise Privatsphäre und
an welcher Stelle ist es nicht mehr
aufklärerisch sondern einfach nur noch
nur noch reißerisch oder was auch immer
oder fand unsere Redaktion haben wir uns
natürlich gerade systemzug mit in
Zusammenhang mit dem Fall auch
unterhalten es war klar dass das bei
tiktok leicht zu bekommen wäre auch
leicht zu recherchieren werde in das
haben wir natürlich gesagt das machen
wir auf gar keinen Fall und haben auch
in unsere Berichterstattung mit
aufgenommen dass
wir dass wir das nicht tun und dass man
das auch nicht tun soll und haben auch
regelrecht gewarnt davor dieses Video zu
verbreiten weil das einfach sehr großen
Schaden anrichtet wenn sie das machen
wenn wir als das kleine sympathische ZDF
das machen dann ist das ja alles gut und
schön nur das mächtigste
Nachrichtenportal der Welt oder Portal
ist Meter ist Facebook Instagram alles
was da zugehört zu diesem Konzept wer
kontrolliert diese Leute ja das ist
sicherlich etwas was
frau Müller hat das gesagt dass da auch
eine politische Debatte stattfinden muss
das Problem ist ein bisschen dass in dem
Moment in dem man eben mit harter Kritik
an diesen sozialen Netzwerken kommt sehr
schnell da steht als altmodisch oder als
jemand der Zensur ausüben möchte ja das
ist ja ganz schlimmer Vorwurf gerade
gegenüber Medien und das ist etwas was
möglicherweise auch politisch richtig
noch mal neu diskutiert werden muss und
ich finde ihre Forderung zu sagen dass
man in so einem Momenten Netzwerk
erstmal abschaltet man das heißt ja
nicht dass man für immer abscheidet man
schaltet es erst einmal ab ja man zieht
erst einmal die Reißleine so wie man im
richtigen Leben wenn irgendwo was
passiert eine Notbremse zieht das ist in
der digitalen Welt bisher überhaupt
nicht gegeben
Frage an Sie die Politik heute hier
sozusagen würden sie sowas mitgehen
also zumindest glaube ich müssen wir mal
in Deutschland zur Kenntnis nehmen und
ich bin außerordentlich dankbar für EU
weil sie beschreiben das was Realität
ist und sie beschreiben das mit dem
Familien aber eben Schule heute auch
fertig werden muss und nicht fertig wird
das ist die Realität und ich finde wenn
in Amerika tatsächlich eine Debatte über
einen Verbot von tiktok geführt wird
dann sollten wir zumindest eine Debatte
bei uns darüber führen ob das am Ende
dann der Weg ist zu sagen wir verbieten
ist oder ob es nicht eher darum geht zu
regulieren und zu sagen es muss auch es
gibt auch Situationen in der man die
Notbremse zieht ich finde die Backen
müssen wir dringend in Deutschland
führen wir führen sie nicht und zwar
sehr schnell nicht also Frau Feser ist
ja auch dazu befragt worden die hat sehr
schnell gesagt nee das machen wir in
Deutschland nicht mit dem Argument na ja
keine Zensur und und
aber das ist glaube ich hilft uns in der
Debatte wenn es um Kinder und
Jugendschutz geht überhaupt nicht und
ich möchte das kurz ergänzen was Frau
Kraftwerk gesagt hat denn genau das
regnet mir ne ich bin wir sind
ausgezeichnet von der BITKOM als Smart
School ich selber bin
digitalbotschafterin des Landes
Niedersachsen vom Wirtschaftsminister
Frage gewesen wie das dazu passt genau
und muss mir natürlich den Vorwurf
gefallen lassen dass es es gibt in der
Bildungssprache diesen vorwurst des
Spitze Rest zu sein dr Spitzer für
digitale Demenz stark macht oder so
Debatte genau
ja tatsächlich muss ich mir diesen
Vorwurf gefallen lassen und der trifft
mich dann natürlich auch direkt das
heißt du diskutierst ja und du
debattierst ja jetzt wie er das mache
ich keinesfalls weil ich bin nicht
Gegner von sozialen Netzwerken ich bin
auch kein Gegner von digitalen
Instrumenten keinesfalls ich setze mich
sogar dafür ein und wir arbeiten bei uns
in der Schule seit 15 Jahren total
digital
und ich glaube auch Stichwort KI
wichtiges Thema das uns in den Schulen
gerade überrollt und einholt dass wir
Null vorbereitet sind gesellschaftlich
was kommt und deswegen ist für mich der
Punkt wenn wir bei diesen
wichtigsten und wirklich kommunikativ
wichtigen Instrumenten die Fehler machen
dass wir nicht eingreifen dass wir nicht
übrigens für Werte und Normen auch mal
Sorgen um digitalen Raum wir haben ja
nichts transformiert überall wo Menschen
zusammentreffen gibt es eigentlich
Regelungen gibt es Werte gibt
arbeiten und schreiben gibt es auch für
uns gibt sehr kleine Regeln und wir
schaffen keine Grundvoraussetzung dafür
dass diese Kinder die in 10 15 Jahren
Verantwortung und übrigens demokratische
Verantwortung übernehmen sollen
überhaupt noch in der Lage sind meine zu
bilden sich einzusetzen tatsächlich sich
für Demokratie einzusetzen und zu
erheben und das ist meine große Sorge
unabhängig davon dass ich viele viele
Kinder sehen sehe die einfach
angegriffen sind weil sie hat Barack
Obama jetzt in Berlin noch darauf
hingewiesen nicht genau wissen was echt
und unecht ist hat
folgende
Obermaier an dem Punkt Fragen also
Obamas Idee zu sagen wir brauchen viel
mehr Medienkompetenz hier steht jetzt
ein anderer Vorschlag im Raum
zeitweise das ist ja nicht dass das
kumulativ ne also wir brauchen beides ne
also
zeitweise abschalten sie sagen nach
Freudenberg hätte man tiktok abschalten
müssen genau aber aus dem ethischen
Kontext genau aber das vielleicht weil
das begegnet mir sonst morgen selber bei
Twitter und so weiter ich bin voll für
Medienkompetenz ich sage sogar wir haben
keine unsere Generation hat keine wir
haben zu laufen lassen super nee noch
hier den Raum lass uns das doch bitte
mal das halten doch aus wenn dann der
Stress kommt ich
da drauf
kann man den Notbremse so charmanze auch
klingt gerade nicht vorstellen wenn man
quasi wegen eines Themas so schrecklich
ist auch ist quasi eine Plattform
abschaltet kann bei einem technisch und
auch ehrlich gesagt der Meinungsfreiheit
nicht so ganz vorstellen geht mir
genauso ich sehe aber den Punkt mit der
Medienkompetenz total ich glaube auch
dass wir da vielleicht hier auch auf
einem Level reden was immer noch weit
entfernt ist von dem Alltag an der
Schule also ich habe nicht so viel
Einblick wie sie ich habe quasi selber
durch den eigenen Nachwuchs den Einblick
und wenn ich mal da anschaue wo eine
Grundschule allein steht dass er die
Frage nicht sind wir abgehängt sondern
wie weit sind wir aufgehängt
allein ganz natürliche Kommunikation mit
einer E-Mail ist das ist Lehrkräfte gibt
wo das auch ein großes Thema ist wie oft
man zum Beispiel eine E-Mail anschaut so
das ist eben nicht was ist was man
einmal in der Woche oder zwei Wochen
macht sondern das ist ein tägliches
Kommunikationsmittel sein könnte auch
durch Corona gibt ja tolle Technologie
wie Kindern die krank sind die
Hausaufgaben mitgeteilt werden wo man
dann auch eklatante Unterschiede gibt
zwischen Lehrern manche die das ganz
natürlich machen in ihren Alltag einfach
eingebaut haben und andere für die das
jetzt einfach schon wieder vergessen ist
mal Corona ist ja gefühlt vorbei es ist
wichtiger Punkt aber tatsächlich dann
noch mal sozusagen die Fortführung davon
Frau Prien an nochmal zurück zu dem zu
dem Thema das wir gerade sprechen diese
diese Gewalt
wir alle haben hier glaube ich in der
Runde Kinder und ähm man hätte das
Gefühl da kommt so eine Generation nach
die sind so wahnsinnig friedliebend sind
alle so pazifistisch unterwegs in
moralisch alle sehr marklos und den
Tiger und sind gute Kinder
und dann plötzlich das
Heide Schleswig-Holstein kleiner Ort in
dem der Bürgermeister plötzlich sagt wir
haben da ein Thema mit Kinder und Jugend
Gewalt wir kriegen das nicht mehr in den
Griff und er sagte auf Nachfrage seit
ungefähr einem Jahr was ist da passiert
Heide ist immerhin eine Stadt also es
ist schon irgendwie ein bisschen mehr
als ein Dorf nein aber ist nicht London
ist nicht Paris ist nicht New York also
das meine ich damit und ganz so ist es
natürlich auch nicht die Polizei agiert
er ja seit ja seit nahezu einem Jahr und
inzwischen sind die Dinge auch
eigentlich ganz gut passiert das ist der
Vorfall ist ja im Februar passiert aber
die ähm wenn man die Gewalt Entwicklung
war ja vorher also die ist Monate vorher
gewesen die Gewalt die Polizei hat
eingegriffen hatten gefährlichen Ort
auch bestimmt können Sie das einmal
beschreiben was ist da passiert ich
kenne es nicht wirklich der Vorteil ist
dass ähm ein Mädchen von mehreren
weiteren Mädchen die von verschiedenen
Schulen kamen aus auch nicht hat auch
nicht an Schule stattgefunden der
Vorfall sondern im
sozusagen in der Freizeit
über Stunden gequält worden ist
körperlich psychisch misshandelt
demütigt
tatsächlich und Moment und das ist das
eine dass das passiert ist und das was
aber die Dinge im potenziert ist das ist
gefilmt worden ist und online gestellt
worden ist und damit sozusagen die Tat
sich immer wieder perpetuiert durch die
Tat immer wieder aufs Neue begangen wird
und auch die
Persönlichkeitsverletzung die Demütigung
ihm immer wieder seinen Vortrag gefunden
hat wissen muss man der Vorfall ist im
Februar passiert öffentlich geworden ist
er erst einige Wochen später da ist das
Video schon vielfach geteilt worden
und
es ist eben dieses was Sie beschreiben
die Verrohung dieses überhaupt kein
keine Empathie empfinden gegenüber einem
anderen Menschen zwischen
Mädchen das muss man auch sagen und zwar
jungen Mädchen also es ist ein Mädchen
das irgendwie 17 ist die anderen sind
alle unterhalb der
strafmündigkeitsgrenze das ist auch ein
Phänomen das eben neu ist jedenfalls in
diesem Ausmaß es sind Mädchen und es
sind sehr junge Kinder und der junge
Jugendliche betroffen ob das ganze ein
Trend ist ich finde da muss man jetzt
noch mal ein bisschen vorsichtig sein
wir können ja am Ende nur die
Kriminalitätsstatistik aus 19 ähm mit
der aus 22 vergleichen 20 und 21 in der
die Zahlen sehr niedrig waren sind nicht
außer gekräftig weil wir da unter
corona-bedingungen die einfach die
Kinder und Jugendlichen nicht sich nicht
entfalten konnten und auch gar nicht
draußen waren das heißt wenn wir 19 und
22 vergleichen dann sehen wir Anstiege
insbesondere bei den jüngeren und bei
den Mädchen aber ob es ein Trend ist ich
finde das muss man einfach das wird man
in den nächsten 12 Jahren sich anschauen
ist aber dass da eine Veränderung im
Gange ist das spüren auch an den Schulen
also sag mal anekdotisch spüren dass
auch die Lehrkräfte sah berichten uns
auch große Gewalten Album bei den bei
den 5-6 klässtern dass sie sagen Frau
Prien ich schließe deswegen auch so habe
ich das verstanden auch eine Änderung
bei der Frage wann beginnt
Strafmündigkeit nicht aus ja wobei das
habe ich zwar gesagt und dazu stehe ich
auch aber ich glaube wichtig ist dass
wir uns insgesamt die Jugend nach Corona
anschauen und ist nicht weil ich jetzt
sage das ist alles durch Corona gekommen
aber ich sage schon dass der Verdacht
dass das Ganze noch mal verstärkt worden
ist und ich glaube wir schulden der
jungen Generation dieser Jugend schulden
wir dass wir da sehr genau draufschauen
und da gehört das Thema Strafmündigkeit
dazu aber das ist nur ein Aspekt und das
gehört eben viel vieles andere mehr auf
dazu trotzdem immer gerne wissen also
was wäre denn dann der Vorschlag bei
Freudenberg ist es ja so gewesen dass
man im Nachhinein festgestellt haben
dass sie die beiden Täterinnen vorher
gegoogelt haben wie das mit der
Strafmündigkeit aussieht also für die
Täterin ist das sehr wohl ein Thema
gewesen die haben also sehr genau
überlegt wenn wir so etwas tun welche
Konsequenzen hat das eigentlich für mich
persönlich und ich meine das ist jetzt
noch mal ich finde das ist echt krass
und insofern
wäre mein petitum sich das genau
anzugucken was da eigentlich passiert
auch mit wissenschaftlernte sich das
genau anzuschauen ich und dann aber
schon zu gucken ob es nicht sinnvoll ist
sich im Einzelfall anzugucken ob
Jugendliche strafmündig sind auch
unterhalb der Grenze von 14 Jahren
mein Ansatz ja konkret zu machen sie
würden 13-jährige ins Gefängnis stecken
Entschuldigung nicht ins Gefängnis bevor
der ins Gefängnis kommt also auch
Strafmaßnahmen bei Jugendlichen sind ja
bevor junge Menschen ins Gefängnis gehen
muss schon viel passieren
bringt also ins Gefängnis aber natürlich
rede ich nicht davon Jugendliche
sozusagen ins Gefängnis zu stecken damit
sie da nicht wieder rauskommen sondern
ich rede davon
dass man pädagogische Maßnahmen
möglicherweise auch im strafrechtlichen
Kontext das ist aber das ist was anderes
es ist ja nicht so dass jemand der noch
nicht strafmündig ist also nicht 14 das
hat ja für den auch Konsequenzen das ist
richtig für die beiden Täterinnen dort
hat das ja auch Konsequenzen nicht so
dass das ohne Konsequenzen bleibt wie es
häufig berichtet wird
genau zu stellen noch mal die Nachfrage
weil sie gerade sagt im strafrechtlichen
Kontext Konsequenzen was heißt das wie
ist eigentlich unsere gesellschaftliche
Norm und natürlich geht es bei
Jugendlichen egal also wenn auch wenn
sie Strafmündigkeit sind immer in aller
erster Linie um die
resozialisierungsfrage das ist und das
ist wirklich auch völlig außer Frage
trotzdem ist die Frage ob wir angesichts
dieser Entwicklung zulassen können dass
junge Menschen auch wenn sie jünger als
14 sind Straftaten in bewusster also in
Kenntnis und dem vollen Bewusstsein dass
sie eine Strafe begehen
agieren lassen ohne ihn auch vor Augen
zu führen dass das absolut genau und
dass das eine absolut gesellschaftlich
nicht tolerierte Tarte ist also das
Gefängnis eine Option ist auf jeden
Falls etwas ist was irgendwann droht ja
aber ich noch mal ganz das Alter ich
will es einfach verstehen wo setzen wir
das an es gibt in den USA Staaten da
kommen weiß ich nicht sechsjährige nicht
genau sie sind ja jemand der sehr
differenziert drauf schaut sind Juristen
sind niemand der auffällig wird durch so
markige Forderungen nach dem Motto jetzt
mal einfach mal den Knast packen
deswegen ist interessant wenn jemand wie
sie mit so einem Argument kommt ja also
ich glaube schon dass wir bei den 12 bis
14-jährige etwas genauer hinschauen
wobei das ist natürlich nur ein Aspekt
dieser ganzen Debatte und da bitte ich
auch drauf zu schauen wir reden werden
das sicherlich nicht nur mit dem
Strafrecht lösen können dass da gar
keine Frage